but things are uh looking really good
for some of our favorite tv hosts oh
yeah
the world is always brighter with
authoritarianism it's bringing some
people
to tears check the story out if i okay
but for those that are listening uh
we're gonna start off this segment with
me asking a simple question and
and don't look if you haven't yet don't
look who do you think cried
when uh joe biden won which which
anchor on tv cried probably all the
right-wingers all right i know this one
but
who is it luke uh miss uh maddow
rachel maddow from the daily mail who is
the big who is media's biggest biden
suck-up rachel maddow cries on air
while al roker fist bumps the president
and the new press secretary jenn sackey
gets a very warm welcome rachel now
said that she'd worked through half a
box of kleenex on
air amazing oh yes weeping on air and
making fun of trump staffers
rachel maddow a well-known trump critic
confessed on her show
that she worked through half a box of
kleenex while watching the day's events
i'm a faucet that can't turn off i
remember the last time she almost cried
on tv
was when the mueller report came back
that donald trump wasn't colluding with
russia
and you could see her struggling not to
cry and there's that really funny video
where the lady is
like filming with her phone and she's
laughing and she goes she crying
oh i love that it went so viral it's
amazing they say abc news's byron pitts
drew criticism
for calling biden the nation's papa in
chief after listening to his inaugural
address
i love this one tweet this uh this new
york times best-selling author
said we can now rest i can no more 3 a.m
waking up with anxiety it's like when
you were a little kid falling asleep in
the back seat knowing that dad was
driving and everything would be okay
and i'm just like i wouldn't want to
fall asleep in the car with no
with joe biden driving it i'd want to be
holding on and i'd be wearing my
seatbelt but here's where it gets
interesting
it wasn't just rachel maddow who was
crying it's also
andrew sullivan isn't andrew sullivan a
conservative
i'm not even sure never trump where
anybody is now yeah i don't think it
matters
he tweeted just walking the dog and
finding myself
in tears relief patriotism the ceremony
the ceremony restored something
inside oh my god that's kind of scary
you know what i mean like
the cult like um uh the cult like a view
of the american
industrial machine you know the people
who look at
uh joe biden and the establishment and
they just want to drop to their knees
and worship the establishment and they
cry
when the establishment power is returned
who is it that was walking their dog
andrew sullivan it's it's like all the
murder and all the death and all of the
authoritarianism they don't care
just well they've got a four year at
least a four year vacation ahead of them
because
you know they don't have to do any
critical reporting they just have to
repeat what's said af
fed to them by the white house press
officer in the dnc
they don't have to do anything anymore
it was so hard
with trump you know like having to do
work
yeah do their jobs yeah and now
literally a lot of their coverage is
aesthetics and the clothing did you see
those sneakers
look at those chucks that kamal harris
is wearing i mean that's literally
i think it was abc news that sat her
down i mean we're talking about one of
the most
important people in our political
discourse right now and you're asking
her about
sneakers i mean are you kidding me there
was another anchor on msnbc
uh that i tweeted about that compared
biden's administration
to the avengers literally says she said
they are superheroes that will quote
save us all i tweeted well he's more
like thanos with the snap of a finger
who's going to take away half of your
income
and uh it's just absolutely ridiculous
to have this kind of glorification of of
politicians
of power which again just shows you the
utter
lack of responsibility and duty that
these supposed journalists have
for their profession it's not a
profession it's literally just brown
nosers here's the issue right
when a bunch of middle american you know
people who lost their job start cheering
for trump
and making these silly drawings of trump
riding a tank and like
or riding a velociraptor i don't care
all that much because they're regular
people
the regular people who believe in donald
trump
when the mainstream corporate media uses
the might of their billions of dollars
to prop
up one political party and destroy
the other that's disconcerting if if i
see a group of people like you know i've
never really cared all that much about
the cue stuff
because i'm like i don't care who these
these people are they can believe they
can have their little forms they can
believe whatever they want i think it's
bad for them i think it led to bad
things and it's sad
but what about the other conspiracy on
the left the crazy russia stuff the
putin
colin donald trump during the capital
riot and they prop it up
you know it's difficult to actually get
in to find these communities that are
full of weird conspiracies
it's difficult it's easy to turn on
msnbc and then hear fake
news and propaganda and insanity and
then start believing it
and they want that q is just a much less
effective version of
cnn and the new york times much less
dangerous
so they create these conspiracies
theories they incite riots with
blm mythology that says that cops are
just going around
gunning down innocent black men because
they're black i mean
they invented this mythol this the the
country burned the entire summer because
of their conspiracy theories
uh q just causes some awkward moments of
thanksgiving
right well a lot of people who stormed
the capital were
cute people like the the viking guy
right so some bad stuff comes in it
right he also believed he was an alien
he was no no no he he well yes but in
the body of a human who br and he
practices life
magic okay and he explained that he was
his presence there was to ward off the
dark magic people who would see him and
then go whoa we got like a
a big player we better back off well
that because his live magic was powerful
yeah that's the insurrection we were
facing could you imagine a government by
that guy
it's like like the national religion
would be the incoherent ramblings on the
dr browner's soap bottles he would
probably get more likes on youtube than
biden
i bet he said i have a feeling he still
thinks that he preserved a bunch of
people's lives he was like if i wasn't
there so many more people would have
died oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and maybe he did he looked kind of funny
like he brought a levity to it
so look the the cue stuff it's it's it's
it bums me out these people just want to
believe it you know they want to believe
that
i'm telling you right now they still
believe trump has got a secret plan
they think the new capital is in florida
and trump is working with the military
and i kid you not because i tweeted this
on the 20th like how long until they
start saying that
you know the real plan was to allow
biden to be president so that way they
would confirm the crime and the treason
had been committed
because if he didn't assume the office
then the treason never happened right
they really believe it sorry no i was
just saying that you know
the way the media decides to focus on
that particular group
it always makes me wonder because they
can never quite answer the questions
that
so like let's say q supporters was five
percent
of the public uh maybe it's significant
but what if it's really like
point five percent is there any other
measurement because they sort of
focus in on this demographic of crazies
and and make it seem like oh that's
common that's mainstream
and they do this constantly with like
they find some extremists or some weirdo
and make it seem like it's
representative of something large when
in fact
it's barely even that entity or it
doesn't exist at all it's with the
caliphate
uh podcast that new york times did it
was completely manufactured
so like all this attention that cues get
who how many people actually
are quote unquote has there been a
survey done that established them as
something more than one percent of the
population if that
yeah but it was given life because of
the major censorship efforts a lot of
people who
spewed the q stuff said well for not
legitimate why is youtube why is google
why
why is facebook and twitter censoring us
and that of course
created a situation where the
conversation didn't take place in front
of everyone
it took place in other parts of the
internet that are far away in seedy
places where crazy people go
to discuss different things and it even
came to a point where
youtube started banning and deleting
videos that were critical
of of cue people so so how
they whenever they get censored they say
over target
yes which is means that oh no like we've
we figured it out that's why they're
reacting this way
they're trying to ban us because we were
right yes jack dorsey actually
sort of admitted this because you
remember after trump was banned off of
twitter
um he sort of and then parlor was kicked
off he made his little tweet thread
and it was very slimy and i don't think
authentic but in the beginning he says
that
banning trump and the other platform you
know what happened to them
has in his words he said caused the
conversation to become fractured
and that's exactly what you're
describing because if we're not all in
the same place talking we can't all
correct the
you know and if somebody goes really far
off the reservation we're all still here
we can just pull them back
and put our arms around them but when
they're off on their own there's the
communication's been broke because
they've been banned off the platform
there was literal people saying okay
let's look at these q drops let's let's
break them down okay this didn't happen
this didn't happen this isn't a surgeon
there's they say this is going to happen
let's actually look at this let's see if
there's any evidence let's see if
there's any documents backing this
nothing and slowly talking people out of
it those videos were deleted
bro from youtube they thought that
mueller was working for trump
they said that mueller they needed a way
to get in a special prosecutor with a
deep state realizing it
and that mueller was pretending to
investigate trump for the press but it
was actually
going to be about hillary clinton and
then it never happened
and they claimed to have found the
location of these camps and they went to
these places and then there was nothing
there
and it was years ago that people like
cernovich and jack bosovic some of the
highest profile trump supporters were
like dude it's not
real people don't want to let it go and
then when
i i remember it's just been you know for
the past several weeks people saying
monday's the day the states are going to
start flipping and the arrests are going
to happen the storm is coming
nothing happens yeah then i remember the
day before inauguration
i had people posting on i see people
posting on facebook tomorrow is the
final day they're waiting for the last
moment and then gets inaugurated
and then all of a sudden there are these
crazy posts popping up like what's
happening what's happening i'm so
confused
and then the next day it's all part of
the plan it's all part of the
part was it a real thing with someone
that actually had info but then it just
got co-opted by
crazy people they're like i'm going to
pretend like i'm cute and tricky no it's
like nostradamus
it's like you know somebody i'm gonna
make a prediction for you right now
the dark eagle the moon
green blades grass
friday at some point in the next several
years someone will find this clip and
they will associate those random things
i just said and be like he was right
i didn't say anything or i could ask
questions so cute as yes questions
why is nancy pelosi wanting machine guns
why is the national guard
refusing to answer why they're there
yeah they asked a lot of questions
that's what q does
ask questions why is the military moving
a plane in the dead of night to joint
base andrews
why did another plane go to texas and
they call themselves queue because
that's the name of that guy from star
trek because
queue clearance what's that the highest
level of security clearance you can get
so they say okay
i don't know if that's true i don't know
well a lot of people attribute what
happened with q as a government-run
psychological operation as a psyop
because if you look at the effects of it
it essentially undermined
not only donald trump but any form of
legitimate criticism of government
you know instead of actually considering
what the government has been doing
the american foreign policy where our
tax dollars are going people were
talking about riddles on the internet
and looking for things that weren't
really there at all from the very
beginning
and when you see the cause and effect a
lot of people are saying hey this was
directly
done in for nefarious purposes that
essentially backfired on anyone who
believed in it thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all
next time
you